some actors would love to return to the
roles that made them famous but
hollywood studios don't always get on
board why won't they make a blossom
reunion how come star trek has frozen
out kirk and wharf keep watching to find
out
raunchy comedian tim allen turned heads
in 1991 when he starred as the decidedly
non-raunchy tim taylor host of the
fictional home renovation show tool time
in the family sitcom home improvement it
became one of the biggest television
hits of the 90s running eight seasons
and launching allen to super stardom the
actor would go on to become the voice of
toy story spaceman buzz lightyear and
receive a star on the hollywood walk of
fame more recently he headlined the
sitcom last man standing another family
sitcom that ran for nine seasons but
despite that the one rule he longs to
return to is tim taylor in 2020 allen
told tv line i always think about it
because i still talk to everybody
involved i like the idea of doing it as
one-off like a one-hour movie i like the
idea of finding out where the boys are
now and where tool time would be in
today's world i just think it's a
marvelous idea and all the actors think
it's a great idea at least he was able
to bring him back for one episode of
last man standing
liam neeson was already an award-winning
hollywood star when he took the part of
qui-gon jinn the wise sagely jedi master
to apprentice obi-wan kenobi in george
lucas's 1999 hit star wars episode 1 the
phantom menace unfortunately qui-gon
would be killed off in the movie's
exciting climax providing a devastating
emotional ending but nothing ever really
ends in 2020 when disney's obi-wan
kenobi stand-alone streaming series
began filming with ewan mcgregor rumors
began swirling that we could also see
nissan return as qui-gon jinn this time
as a force ghost the mystical spirit of
a dead jedi that fans have previously
seen in the star wars saga asked about a
possible return for his character neeson
denied the rumors but said with a big
smile that he would love to come back
considering he's reprised the role
before for the clone wars animated
series the idea that he might return to
live action makes sense if scenes with a
ghost can be called live action
scott bakula recently wrapped a
seven-season stint as dwayne pride on
ncis new orleans but he probably
wouldn't have a career if not for his
iconic role as physicist and unwitting
time traveler sam beckett in the
memorable abc adventure series quantum
leap as the amnesia-stricken scientists
displaced in time beckett left into the
life of a different person each week
with bakula flexing his acting chops by
essentially playing a different
character every episode beckett used his
moral imperative to fix the past and put
right what once went wrong battling
injustice and saving lives week after
week for five seasons until the show
ended its run in may of 1993. bakula has
been talking about a potential revival
for quantum leap for nearly 20 years
more recently when he appeared on bob
sagg's podcast here for you he seemed to
suggest that it may be coming sooner
rather than later telling sagat there
are very significant conversations about
it right now going on i don't know what
it would be i don't know who would have
it the rights were a mess for years i
don't know if they're even sorted out
now that's always been the biggest
complication
for seven years michael doran played the
stoic klingon warrior lieutenant wharf
on the star trek franchise revival star
trek the next generation from there
dorne would make the leap to the big
screen appearing in four next generation
feature films and in an attempt to boost
ratings the star trek spin-off deep
space nine saw him reprise his role and
be back on the small screen for its
final four years making michael doran
the actor with the most appearances in
star trek history you'd think
277 episodes and four movies would be
enough for the actor especially under
all that heavy makeup but dorne has been
campaigning to return as an older wiser
captain wharf since at least 2012 only
in 2017 when cbs launched star trek
discovery and began building an entire
universe of star trek spin-offs for
their streaming service did the idea of
headlining his own show really become a
possibility and dorne is excited about
what it could mean in 2021 dorne sat
down with trekmovie.com and said he was
even able to meet with paramount and
pitch his proposed series that would see
worf take the captain's chair aboard a
klingon ship basically the script i
wrote was instead of looking at the
klingon empire from starfleet we look at
starfleet from the klingon empire it
sounds like a compelling idea and the
actor is clearly frustrated by
paramount's seeming lack of interest i
chuckle because sometimes i think that
they're going you know we need something
on this streaming app we need somebody
that's done more star trek than anybody
god who do you think what about michael
dorn no he's not right
john bernthal came to fame on the
walking dead but it was when he made the
jump to the marvel universe debuting on
daredevil as frank castle aka marvel's
the punisher that he was gifted with
perhaps his most iconic role his stint
in the second season of the netflix
drama was met with praise from critics
and a spin-off became a no-brainer this
ran for two seasons before contract
issues between netflix marvel prompted
its conclusion rumor has it that marvel
may bring back bernthal and punisher in
the upcoming disney plus series echo in
2021 bernthal told forbes that he didn't
know whether those rumors were true or
not but he hoped so he said honestly i
have no idea that isn't just the
standard answer i just don't think the
question is about whether they're going
to do it it's going to be about how they
do it and whether we can do it in a way
the character and the fans deserve as
far as going on in the future it's a
character that i really feel like that i
have in my bones and in my heart
mass mickelson was already a star and
had at least one iconic role under his
belt as the villain in the james bond
blockbuster casino royale when he took
on the part of hannibal lecter in the
small screen adaptation of thomas
harris's long-running series created by
showrunner brian fuller hannibal was a
reimagining of the characters featured
in the hit novels red dragon and silence
of the lamps it was set before the
stories in the books fleshing out the
relationship between young fbi agent
will graham and psychologist hannibal
lecter in the hit tv series the latter
half of the third season had already
translated red dragon in its entirety
and everyone was gearing up for a
potential fourth season that would
feature hannibal helping graham hunt
down a new serial killer named buffalo
bill the main antagonist in silence of
the lambs when the series was abruptly
cancelled there has long been talk of a
revival to finish that part of the story
and mikkelsen has said that he's ready
willing and waiting telling vulture i
would love to go back everybody wants to
go back and if there's only one season
and we're sure about that brian fuller
can finish it in a proper surprising
stunning way carl urban is fortunate
enough to have inhabited several major
roles in his career from the lord of the
rings to star trek but it's his lone
appearance in 2012's dread that has him
itching to return to a different fan
favorite role that's a violent future
peacekeeper judge dredd though the film
didn't soar at the box office it has
become a cult classic and attempts to
make a sequel have been stop and go for
the better part of the decade with urban
himself campaigning for more in august
of 2020 he talked to screen geek about
bringing dread back with the same group
who made the first one i've gone on the
record before saying that i would love
to come back and be a part of that world
and tell more dread stories there is
just a plethora of great great stories
within the judge dredd universe and if i
get the opportunity you can bet your
bottom dollar i will be there because i
think that it would be just a really
rich and rewarding experience for not
only for us to collaborate but for the
fans
in 1993 warner brothers created lois and
clark the new adventures of superman
making star dean kane a household name
also starring terry hatcher as lois lane
the series ran for four years and nearly
90 episodes but it's probably more
important to television history for its
unique mix of family drama comic book
action and soap opera tone that set a
new standard for the genre in 2019 kane
spoke to entertainment tonight about the
possibility of a return as clark kent
and the man of steel saying of a
possible revival of the series i would
love to see that happen because i think
we ended on the weirdest note ever and
so we've talked about it and i would
love to see what they are doing 25 years
later and i'd love to see that situation
i've already started writing little bits
and pieces down so we'll see if i can
convince someone to make 6 10 12
episodes
there was a time in the career of
william shatner that he may not have
fully embraced his fame as james t kirk
so when the producers of star trek
generations wish to bring kirk back one
last time and kill off captain kirk in
the process shatner seemingly had no
qualms seeming ready to say goodbye to
the character
but he apparently regretted the decision
to allow his character to die because in
1995 he co-wrote the first in a series
of novels that brought kirk back from
the dead and has for the better part of
the last two decades campaigned for a
return to the franchise that made him
famous in 2004 shatner himself suggested
an idea to producers of star trek
enterprise that would have seen him
return as an alternate reality version
of kirk and in 2008 he expressed
dissatisfaction with jj abrams for
bringing back leonard nimoy as mr spock
but not himself as kirk in 2017 with the
new series star trek discovery debuting
shatner said all it would take to get
him to return would be quote a great
deal of money and while that may not
seem like a great deal of enthusiasm he
recently remarked that he'd love to come
back as kirk for the upcoming movie
scheduled for 2023 live long and prosper
captain kirk the harry potter film
series catapulted a number of young
actors to super stardom from daniel
radcliffe and emma watson to robert
pattinson the next batman but actor tom
felton found in the series a
career-making role as the slimy draco
malfoy his appearances in all eight
harry potter movies built a solid
foundation for the young thespian to
build a career and he has since been
seen in rise of the planet of the apes
and cw's the flesh but if there's one
role that felton wants to play again
it's definitely draco malfoy who we last
saw in harry potter and the deathly
hallows part 2 in 2011. actually he'd
settle for any malfoy in june of 2021
felton spoke to people magazine about
his legacy as the famous slytherin and
his response to a query about potential
interest in playing the role again was
met with nothing less than unbridled
enthusiasm if you're asking me will i
dye my hair blonde again to be draco
abso bloody lutely either as draco or
lucius i'll play draco's kid if you
really want any chance to be a malfoy
again would be greatly accepted patton
oswalt has a long career that
encompasses everything from sitcoms to
big budget feature films and many years
of stand-up comedy perhaps what makes
him unique among many of his peers is
that he is a fan in addition to being an
actor after years working in hollywood
oswald now has enough of a career that
he can pick and choose his roles with a
tendency to select projects he's already
a fan of such as his role on marvel's
agents of shield so it goes without
saying that when oswald expresses
excitement for a role it comes from a
sincere place especially when it's one
he's already done before and the part he
seems most keen to revisit is pixar's
ratatouille the animated epic about a
rodent chef in paris in an interview
with deadline oswalt was asked if he
would ever have interest in a
ratatouille series or a movie sequel oh
absolutely any sequel to ratatouille
hinges on brad bird coming up with an
idea that he likes and would want to
pursue i love that pixar goes with the
pace of the creators they wait until
something amazing happens so if he drew
up something that would mean that a
truly big inspiration had hit him and he
wants to do it i would absolutely run
and do that
henry cavill's debut as superman in the
2013 film man of steel was nearly a
decade in the making cavill had
auditioned for brian singer's superman
returns however that movie would
eventually cast brandon routh in the
title rule but fate was kind to the
young actor for the rejection made his
casting in zack snyder's dc film
possible he then returned to the role in
justice league and batman vs superman
dawn of justice
but given that a new superman film was
recently announced and it's meant to
feature a new black man of steel does
that mean cavill's time in tights is
over not necessarily cavill told the
hollywood reporter that he feels like he
has unfinished business especially when
it comes to superman killing general zod
at the end of man of steel there is
still a lot of storytelling for me to do
as superman and i would absolutely love
the opportunity there's an opportunity
for growth after that to explore the
psyche of superman as a deep seemingly
invulnerable god-like being but with
real feeling on the inside as i always
say the cape is still in the closet
mayan bialik may be best known today as
dr amy farah fowler neuroscientist and
geeky love interest for sheldon on the
big bang theory but long before her
stint on the big bang theory bialik was
better known as blossom the smart sassy
eccentric teen with a unique fashion
sense far from the awkward amy blossom
was a cool and funky emotionally
self-aware teen who dished out wisdom
and advice each week blossom was a slow
starter in the ratings but eventually
became a hit running five years on nbc
where it got good reviews for its
touching family stories about the life
of a 90s teenager saved for a handful of
voice acting roles bialik left acting
after blossom ended its run to pursue
her education eventually earning her phd
in 2007 but now that bialik is back
acting starring in shows like the fox
sitcom call me cat she wouldn't mind
returning to where it all began for her
in fact she's been working closely with
blossom creator don rio to develop a new
blossom show but so far hasn't been able
to find a home for the project bialik
told entertainment weekly don rio and i
do have a limited reboot that we would
like to do but we've had a lot of
trouble getting our network on board so
what would we find blossom up to 30
years later bialyx says she'd probably
be a civil rights attorney or someone
working with children who were removed
from their homes she'd be doing
something humanitarian
in the 1997 james bond spoof austin
powers international man of mystery 23
year old seth green had a memorable role
as the more ordinary son of the hero's
supervillain nemesis dr evil appearing
in both sequels the character of scot
evil at first resents and even mocks his
father's choice to try to get rich or
take over the world through harebrained
schemes i hate you i hate you i wish i
was never artificially created in a lab
over the course of the trilogy though
the father and son eventually find
common ground and the young mastermind
eventually comes to embrace his destiny
and become a super villain himself in
the final film of the series in the
final moments of gold member scott evil
takes his father's place as the enemy of
austin powers and implies a continued
threat to the british super spy
audiences assumed this was a hint at a
fourth film but a third sequel never
materialized and 20 years after the last
film released in 2002 fans are still
waiting
and apparently so is green who was asked
about a possible sequel by the observer
in 2021 green said my position is the
same i love those movies and it's one of
the most special and awesome things i've
ever gotten to be a part of but the
creation of new stuff rests solely on
mike meyer's interest or willingness to
make something and i don't know that
that's something he wants to do with
that said if there was an idea i would
go back for it it was so much fun just
to hang out with that gang i think any
of us would do it
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]